When I became a dad, I made a choice to support my daughter's dreams.
You don't have enough money.
It says right here we got 401,000 dollars.
Jackpot!
You missed it.
Uh, that says you have a 401k account.
Alex thinks we can afford tuition and we can't.
We gotta lie.
That's what parents do because otherwise our kid's gonna realize that...
...we don't know what we're doing.
Welcome.
I have a way for you guys to make four years tuition in one month:...
...underground casino!
Do the math.
It seems to check out.
Do this math.
You're 40 years old and you go to jail for 20 years.
How old are you when you get out?
No.
Hundred.
Honey!
If I have some scratch paper, I can figure it out.
You wanna make money like Vegas, you gotta look like Vegas.
I am not gonna tell my daughter she can't go to college...
...so we resorted to a life of crime.
Guys, we got a problem.
He's cheating!
We gotta send a message, like De Niro in "Casino."
You think you can cheat us?
What are you guys gonna do about it anyway?
Oh, I'm so scared.
I'm gonna do this.
No, I'm gonna do this!
Hey, hey, hey!
Don't play around with the ax, come on!
Tell your friends if they mess with us, this is what you're gonna get.